never mind
after President Vladimir Putin mobilized
ordinary Russians to fight in Ukraine in
September large protests broke out
families mourn conscripts who died on
the front lines and hundreds of
thousands of Russian men fled the
country
but these are the images that Russians
are seeing on state media
National Television showed the president
firing a rifle and inspecting
preservists who looked all set to fight
and citizens say on air they are fully
prepared for combat
as Putin faces a backlash against
immobilization here's how the state
propaganda machine has stepped in to try
to reassure the population
when the mobilization was announced
State tv reported that men were flocking
to recruitment centers out of patriotism
and it showed smiling families sending
their loved ones to war the Russian army
said it was drafting ordinary citizens
to help hold the front lines in Ukraine
and Ankara said the population responded
with a wave of support
those reports came as recruitment
centers were being targeted by a series
of attacks and polls showed growing
anxiety among Russians
according to an independent pollster the
number of Russians who think that the
campaign in Ukraine is going as planned
dropped to 53 percent of September from
73 in May
days after announcing the mobilization
Putin admitted that the way the draft
was managed raised many questions
but in October the kremlins start to
face criticism as new recruits start on
the front lines just days after being
summoned some families say they were
poorly trained
foreign
about equipment shortages saying they
had to buy things such as flashlights or
sleeping bags themselves
so news reports start to regularly cover
those themes mobilize men going through
battle drills dressed in mint condition
uniforms and equipped with all the gear
needed for combat helmets bulletproof
vests and sleeping bags
and the president himself went on camera
and gave a word of encouragement to the
new draftees
noise
it's hard to tell how effective the
state propaganda is according to border
authorities in Europe and other
countries more than 300 000 Russians
have left the territory since late
September many say they fled to avoid
being sent to war
still many Russians expressed strong
support for the invasion of Ukraine and
are not averse to the mobilization
foreign foreign
the Kremlin said that even though there
were problems of the mobilization the
situation shouldn't be generalized
according to Putin reservists can be
sent to the front lines after 10 to 25
days of training
in late October handout footage from the
Russian government showed Russia's
Minister of Defense telling Putin that
the mobilization was successfully
concluding with some 300 000 men drafted
however many Russians say they are
skeptical the president didn't sign an
official decree to end the draft saying
it wasn't necessary
this has fueled concerns that the
mobilization could resume at any moment
as Russia continues to suffer setbacks
in Ukraine